The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This
is very exciting.
In the previous
lecture, we learned
all about buffer
overflow attacks,
and today we're
going to continue
to discuss some techniques
to launch these attacks.
So, the basic idea of all
these buffer overflow attacks
is as follows.
So, first of all, they leverage
a couple different facts.
So, one thing that they
leverage is that system software
is often written in C.
And so by system
software, I mean things
like databases, compilers,
network servers,
things like that.
And you can also think of things
like your favorite command
shell.
All of those types of things
are typically written in C. So,
why are these things
typically written in C?
Well, they're written in
C because our community,
of course, is
obsessed with speed.
And so C is supposed to be
like high-level assembly,
it takes us very close to the
hardware, and so as a result,
all these very mission
critical systems
are written in this
very low level language.
Now, the problem with
things being written in C
is that C actually exposes
raw memory Addresses.
Right?
And so not only does it
expose raw memory addresses,
but it also performs no
bounds checking when programs
manipulate those raw addresses.
Right?
And so as you can imagine,
this is a recipe for disaster.
OK?
So, once again, why doesn't
C check these bounds?
Well, one reason is because
the hardware doesn't do that.
And people who
write in C typically
want the max amount
of speed possible.
The other reason is that in
C, as we'll discuss later,
it can actually be very
difficult to determine
the semantics of what it
means to have a pointer that's
actually in bounds.
So, in some cases, it would
be very difficult for the C
runtime to
automatically do that.
Now we'll discuss
some techniques
which will actually
try to do that type
of automatic inference.
But as we'll see, none
of these techniques
are fully bulletproof.
And so these attacks
also leverage knowledge
of the x86 architecture.
And by knowledge of
that architecture
I mean things like what's the
direction that the stack grows,
right?
What are the calling
conventions for functions?
When you invoke a C
function, what is the stack
going to look like?
And when you allocate
an object on the heap,
what are those chief allocation
structures going to look like?
And so let's look
at a simple example.
It's very similar to
something that you
saw in the last lecture.
So, we've got you're standard
read request up here.
And then you've got a buffer.
That's here.
And by now you've probably
trained your lizard brain
instincts-- whenever you
see a buffer you're probably
filled with fear-- that
is the right attitude.
And so we've got
the buffer up here,
and then we've got
the canonical int i.
And then we've got the
infamous "gets" command.
And then you've got
some other stuff here.
Right?
So as we discussed
in lecture last week,
this is problematic, right?
Because this gets operation
here does not actually
check the bounds on the buffer.
So, what can happen is that
if the user actually supplies
the buffer-- and actually put
that guy up here, for example--
if that buffer comes
in from the user
and we use this
unsafe function here,
we can actually
overflow this buffer.
We can actually rewrite
stuff that's on the stack.
So, just a reminder of
what that stuff looks
like-- let's look at a
stack diagram here-- so
let's say here we've got I.
Let's say here we've got a buf
Right?
So, we've got the first
address of buffer here.
We've got the last one up here.
I apologize for my
handwriting, I'm
used to writing on
the marker board.
You should pray for me.
So, anyways, then up here,
we've got the saved value
of the break pointer.
We've got the return address
for the function there.
And then we've got some other
stuff from the previous frame.
So, don't forget, we've
got the stack pointer,
which goes there.
And then we've got the new
break pointer, which goes here.
The entry stack
pointer goes there,
and then somewhere
up here, we've
got the entry break point.
Right?
So, just as a reminder, the way
that the Stack Overflow works
is that basically,
it goes this way.
Right?
So, when the gets
operation is called,
we start writing bytes into
buf, and eventually it's
going to start overwriting these
things that are on the stack.
And so this is
basically-- should all
look pretty familiar to you.
So.
What does the attacker do
to take advantage of that?
Basically supplies
that long input.
And so the key idea here is that
this can be attacker-supplied.
And so, if this return address
is attacker-supplied, then
basically the
attacker can determine
where this function's
going to jump to
after [INAUDIBLE] execution.
So, what can the attacker
do once it's actually
been able to hijack
that return address,
and jump wherever it wants.
Well, basically
the attacker is now
running code with the
privileges of the process
that it's just
hijacked, for example.
So, if that process was
a high priority process,
let's say it was running
root, or admin, whatever
they call the super-user of
your favorite operating system,
then now, that program, which
is controlled by the attacker,
can do whatever it wants
using the authority
of that high-priority program.
So, it can do things, like
it could maybe read files,
it can send spam, let's say if
you corrupted a mail server.
It can even do things like
actually defeat firewalls,
right, because the
idea of a firewall
is that there's going
to be this distinction
between good machines that
are behind the firewall
and bad machines that are
outside of the firewall.
So, typically machines are
inside of the firewall,
they have a lot of
trust with each other.
But if you can
subvert a machine that
is actually inside the
firewall, right, that's great.
Because now you can just sort of
skip past a lot of those checks
that those machines don't have
because they think that you're
a trusted individual.
So, one thing you
might be thinking,
or I remember I was thinking
this when I was a student,
was, "OK, fine,
so I've showed you
how to do this buffer
overflow, but why
didn't the OS stop this?
Right?
Isn't the OS supposed
to be that thing that's
sort of sitting around like
Guardians of the Galaxy
and defending all this kind
of evil stuff from happening?"
The thing to note is that the
OS actually isn't watching you
all the time.
Right?
The hardware is
watching all the time.
It's the thing that's actually
fetching instructions,
and decoding them, and
doing things like that.
But to a first approximation,
what does the OS do?
It basically sets up
some page table stuff,
and then it basically
lets you, the application,
run, and if you ask the
operating system for services--
so for example, you want
to send a network packet,
or you want to do some
IPC, or things like that,
then you'll invoke
a system call,
and you'll actually
trap into OS.
But other than that,
the operating system
is not looking at each
and every instruction
that your application
is executing.
So, in other words, when
this buffer overflowed,
it's not like the
operating system
was looking at each of these
memory axises for signs
that [INAUDIBLE].
Right?
All of this address
space belongs
to you, this [INAUDIBLE]
process right,
so you get to do with it what
you want to do with it, right?
Or at least this is the whole
C attitude towards life, right?
Life fast, die young.
So.
That's why the operating system
can't help you right there.
So, later in the lecture,
we will discuss some things
that the operating system can
do with respect to the hardware
so that it can help protect
against these types of attacks.
Once again, it's actually
just the hardware
that's interposing on every
little thing that you do.
So, you can actually
take advantage
of some of that
stuff, for example,
using special types of
[INAUDIBLE] protections
and things like that, that we'll
discuss a little bit later.
That's basically
an overview of what
the buffer overflow looks like.
So, how are we gonna
fix these things?
So, one fix for
avoiding buffer overflow
is to simply avoid
bugs in your C code.
This has the nice advantage of
being correct by construction,
right.
If you don't have any
bugs in your program,
ipso facto the attacker cannot
take advantage of any bugs.
That's on the
professor, I get paid
to think about something
deeply like that.
Now, this of course, is
easier said than done.
Right?
There's a couple of very
straightforward things
that programmers can do to
practice good security hygiene.
So, for example, functions
like this gets function, right?
These are kind of
like go-tos, these
are now known to be bad ideas.
Right?
So, when you compile your
code, and you include functions
like this-- if you're using
a modern compiler, GCC,
Visual Studio, whatever, it will
actually complain about that.
It'll say, hey, you're one
of these unsafe functions.
Consider using
[? FGADS ?], or using
a version of [INAUDIBLE]
that actually
can track the bounds of things.
So, that's one simple thing
that programmers can do.
But note that a
lot of applications
actually manipulate
buffers without necessarily
calling one of these functions.
Right?
This is very common in network
servers, things like that.
They'll define their own
custom parsing routines,
then make sure that
things are extracted
from the buffers in
the way that they want.
So, just restricting yourself
to these types of things
won't solve the
problem completely.
So, another thing that makes
this approach difficult
is that it's not always obvious
what is a bug in a C program.
So, if you've ever worked on a
very large scale system that's
been written in C, you'll
know that it can be tricky
if you've got some function
definition that takes then
18 void star pointers.
I mean, only Zeus knows what
all those things mean, right?
And so it's much more
difficult in a language like C,
that has weak typing
and things like that,
to actually understand
as a programmer
what it means to
have a bug, and what
it means to not have a bug.
OK?
So, in general, one
of the main themes
that you'll see in this
class is that C is probably
the spawn of the devil, right?
And we use it
because, once again,
we typically want to
be to be fast, right?
But as hardware gets
faster and as we
get more and better languages to
write large-scale systems code,
we'll see that maybe
it doesn't always
make sense to write
your stuff in C. Even
if you think it has to be fast.
So, we'll discuss some of
that later and later lectures.
So, that's one
approach, avoiding bugs
in the first place.
So, another approach--
is to build tools that
allow programmers to find bugs.
And so an example
of this is something
that's called static analysis.
Now we'll talk a little bit
more about static analysis
in later lectures,
but suffice it
to say that static analysis is
a way of analyzing the source
code of your program
before it even runs
and looking for
potential problems.
So, imagine that you have
a function like this.
So, the [INAUDIBLE]
foo function,
it takes in a pointer.
Let's say it declares
an integer offset value.
It declares another
pointer and adds the offset
to that pointer.
Now, even just at this
moment in the code,
right, static
analysis can tell you
that this offset variable
is un-initialized.
Right?
So, essentially you can
do things like saying,
is there any way,
is there any control
floating through this program
by which offset could have been
initialized before
it was actually used
this in this calculation here.
Now, in this example it is very
simple to see the answer is no.
Right?
You can imagine that if there
were more branches, or things
like this, it would be
more difficult to tell.
But one thing that a static
analysis tool can tell you,
and in fact, one thing that
[? popular ?] compilers will
tell you, is you'll compile
this, and it'll say, hey buddy,
this has not been initialized.
Are you sure, is this
what you want to do?
So, that's one very simple
example of static analysis.
Another example of what you can
do is, let's say after this,
we have a branch condition here.
Right?
So, you say, if the offset
is greater than eight, then
we'll call some function
bar, and passing the offset.
Now, one thing you
can note about this
is that this branch condition
here actually tells us
something about what
the value of offset is.
Right?
Ignoring the fact that
it wasn't initialized ,
we do know that
once we get here,
we know the offset actually
has to be greater than eight.
So, in some cases,
what we can do
is actually propagate that
constraint, that notion
that the offset must
be greater than eight,
into our analysis of bar.
Right?
So, when we start
statically analyzing bar,
we know that offset can
only take certain values.
So, once again, this is a
very high-level introduction
to static analysis,
and we'll discuss
it more in later lectures.
But this is a basic
intuition of how
we might be able to
detect some types of bugs
without even
executing your code.
So, does that all makes sense?
So, another thing you
can think about doing too
is what they call
program fuzzing.
So, the idea behind
program fuzzing
is that essentially you take all
of the functions in your code,
and then essentially throw
random values for input
to those functions.
And so the idea is that
you want to have high code
coverage for all of your tests.
So, if you go out
in the real world,
typically when you
check in unit test,
you can't just do things like,
I tried values two, four, eight,
and 15, because 15
is an odd number,
so I probably tested
all the branches right.
What you actually
have to do is you
have to look at things like,
like I said how many branches
in the program overall were
actually touched by your test
code, right?
Because that's typically
where the bugs hide.
The programmers don't think
about the corner cases,
and so as a result, they do
have some unit tests that pass.
They even have bigger
tests that pass.
But they're not actually
pinning all the corner
cases in the program.
So, static analysis can actually
help with this fuzzing here.
Once again, using things like
this notion of constraint.
So, for example, in
this program here, we
have this branch condition
here that specified the offset
being greater than eight.
So, we can know what that
offset is statically.
So, we can make sure that if
we're automatically generating
fuzzed inputs, we can ensure
that one of those inputs
hopefully will ensure
that, somehow, offset is
less than eight, one will ensure
that offset's equal to eight,
one will ensure that
it's greater than eight.
So, does that all make sense?
Cool.
So, that's the basic idea behind
the notion of building tools
to help programmers find bugs.
So, the nice thing is that
even partial analysis can
be very, very useful,
particularly when
you're dealing with C.
A lot of these tools
that we'll discuss, to prevent
against things like buffer
overflow or
initialized variables,
they can't catch
all the problems.
Right?
But they can actually give us
forward progress towards making
these programs more secure.
Now, of course, the
disadvantage of these things
is that they're not complete.
Forward progress is
not complete progress.
And so it's still
a very active area
of research of how you defend
against security exploits in C
and just in programs in general.
So, those were two approaches
to deal with defending
against buffer overflow.
There's actually some
other approaches.
So, a third approach you
might think about using
is the use [INAUDIBLE].
And so examples of these are
things like Python, Java, C#--
I'm not going to put up Pearl
there because people who use
Pearl are bad people.
So you can use a memory-safe
language like that.
And this is to a certain extent
seems like the most obvious
thing that you could do.
I just told you over
there that basically C
is high-level assembly code,
and it exposes raw pointers
and does all these things
that you don't want it to do,
and it doesn't do
things you do want
it to do, like [INAUDIBLE].
So, why not just use one of
these high level languages?
Well, there's a couple
reasons for that.
So, first of all, there's
actually a lot of legacy code
that's out there.
Right?
So, it's all fine and dandy
if you want go out and start
your new project and
you want to write it
in one of these
really safe languages.
But what if you've been
given this big binary
or this big source code
distribution that's
been written in C, it's been
maintained for 10, 15 years,
it's been this
generational project,
I mean our children's children
will be working on it.
You can't just say, I'm just
going to write everything in C#
and change the world.
Right?
And this isn't just a
problem in C, for example.
There's actually
systems that you
use that you should be
afraid, because they actually
use Fortran and COBOL code.
What?
That's stuff from the Civil War.
So, why does that happen?
Once again, the
reason why it happens
is because as engineers,
we kind of want to think,
oh, we can just build everything
ourselves, it'll be awesome,
it'll be just the
way that I want it,
I'll call my variables
the things that I want.
When in world, that
doesn't happen.
Right?
You show up on your job, and
you have this thing that exists,
and you look at the code
base, and you say, well,
why doesn't it do this?
And then you say, listen.
We'll deal with that in V2.
But for now, you
got to make things
work because the customers
are taking away their money.
So, there's basically this
huge issue of legacy code here,
and how do we deal with it?
And as you'll see the with
the baggy bounds system,
One of the advantages of
it is that it actually
inter-operates quite well
with this legacy code.
So, anyway, this is one
reason why you can't just
necessarily make all these
buffer overflow problems go
away by using one of these
memory-safe languages.
So, another challenges
is that what if you need
low-level access to hardware?
This might happen if you're
writing something like a device
driver or something like that.
So, in that case,
you really do need
that the benefits
that C gives you
in terms of being
able to look at
registers and
actually understand
a little of [INAUDIBLE]
and things like that.
There's another thing too,
which people always bring up
and which I've alluded to
before, but it's performance.
Right?
So, if you care
about performance,
typically the thing
that you're told
is you've got to
write in C, otherwise
you're just going to
be so slow, you're
going to get laughed out of
code academy or whatever.
Now, this is increasingly
less of an issue.
Like the perf stuff.
Because people have
actually gotten very good
with doing things like
making better compilers
that have all kinds of
powerful optimizations.
And also, there are
these things called
Gits which actually
really reduce
the cost of using these
memory-safe languages.
So, have you guys
heard of Gits before?
So, I'll give you a very brief
introduction to what it is.
The idea is that, think
about a language like Java,
or JavaScript.
It's very high level,
it's dynamically tight,
right, it has automatic heat
management, things like that.
So, typically, when these
languages first came out,
they were always interpreted.
Right?
And by interpreted I
mean they didn't actually
execute raw x86 instructions.
Instead, these languages
were compiled down
to some type of
intermediate form.
You may have heard of things
like the JVM, the Java Virtual
Machine byte code,
things like that.
Right?
You basically had a
program that sat in a loop
and took these byte
codes, and basically
executed the high
level instruction that
was encoded in that byte code.
So, for example, some
of the JVM byte codes
dealt with things like
pushing and popping
things up on the stack.
So, you have a program that
would go through a loop,
operate that stack, and
simulate those operations.
OK.
So, that all seemed
fine and dandy, but once
again, all of the speed
freaks out there were like,
what about the perf?
This too slow.
You've got sort of
that interpreter
sitting in that
loop, and getting
in the way of our bare
metal performance.
So, what people started to do is
actually take these high level
interpreter languages
and dynamically
generate X86 code
for them on the fly.
Right?
So, in terms of just in
time compilation, that
means I take your
snippet of JavaScript,
I take your snippet
of Java whatever,
and I actually spend a
little bit of time upfront
to create actual raw
machine instructions.
Raw x86 that will run
directly on the bare metal.
So, I take that initial
performance hit for the Git
compilation, but then after
that, my program actually
does run on the raw hard drive.
Right?
So, things like
the perf argument
are not necessarily
as compelling
as they used to be,
because of stuff like this.
There's also some crazy
stuff out there, like ASN.js.
So, we can talk more
about this offline
if you actually are
a JavaScript packer.
But there are actually
some neat tricks
that you can do,
like compiling down
JavaScript to very restricted
subset of the language that
only operates on arrays.
Right, so what this allows
you to do is actually get rid
of a lot of the dynamic
typing overhead in standard
JavaScript, and you can actually
get JavaScript code now to run
within 2x of raw C
or C++ performance.
2x might sound like
a lot, but it used
to be things like 10x or 20z.
So, we're actually making a
lot of progress on that front.
And so the other thing to
keep in mind with performance,
too, is that a lot of times, you
don't need performance as much
you might think that you do.
Right?
So, think about it like this.
Let's say that your program
is actually IO bound.
So, it's not CPU bound.
In other words, let's
say that your program
spends most of its time
waiting for network input,
waiting for disk input,
waiting for user input,
things like that.
In those types of cases,
you don't actually
need to have blazing
fast raw compute speed.
Right?
Because your program
actually isn't
spending a lot of time
doing that kind of stuff.
So, once again, this
perf argument here,
you've got to take this
stuff with a grain of salt.
And I actually
see a lot students
who struggle with this.
So, for example,
I'll ask someone
to go out and write me
a very simple program
to parse a text file.
So, they spend all this time
trying to get this to work in C
or C++ and it's super fast and
uses the templates and all that
kind of stuff.
But it's like a one
line solution in Python.
And it essentially
runs just as fast.
And you could develop
it much, much easier.
So, you just have to
take these perf arguments
with a grain of salt.
So, anyway, we've discussed
the three ways you can possibly
avoid buffer overflow.
So, just avoid bugs
in the first place.
LOL, that's difficult to do.
Approach two, you can
build tools to help
you discover those bugs.
Then approach three
is, in a certain sense,
you can push those
tools into the runtime.
You can actually hopefully
rely on some of their language
runtime features to prevent
you from seeing raw memory
addresses.
And you can do things
like balance checking,
and so on and so forth.
Once again, as we
discussed before,
there's a lot of legacy
C and C++ code out there.
So, it's difficult to apply
some of these techniques,
particularly number
two and number three,
if you've got to deal
with that legacy code.
So, how can we do buffer
overflow mitigation
despite all these challenges?
Besides just, you know, dropping
out of computer science classes
and becoming a painter,
or something like that.
So, what actually is going
on in a buffer overflow?
So, in a buffer overflow the
attacker exploits two things.
So, the first thing that the
attack is going to exploit
is gaining control over
the instruction pointer.
Right?
And by this, I mean that
somehow, the attacker
figures out
someplace in the code
that it can make the program
jump to against the program's
will.
Now, this is necessary but
insufficient for an attack
typically to happen.
Because the other thing that
the attacker needs to do
is basically make that pointer
point to malicious code.
Right?
So, how are we going to
basically make the hijacked
IP, instruction pointer,
point to something
that does something
useful for the attacker.
So, what's interesting
is that in many cases,
it's often fairly
straightforward
for the attacker to put some
interesting code in a memory.
So we looked at some of
those shell code attacks
in the last lecture, where you
can actually embed that attack
code in a string.
As we'll discuss a
little bit today and more
in the next lecture,
you can actually
take advantage of some
of the pre-existing code
the application has and
jump to in an unexpected way
to make some evil things happen.
So, typically, figuring out what
code the attacker wants to run,
maybe that's not as
challenging as actually
being able to force
the program to jump
to that location in memory.
And the reason why
that's tricky is
because, basically, the
attacker has to know in some way
where it should jump to.
Right?
So, as we'll see in a
second, and as you actually
saw in the last lecture, a lot
of these shell code attacks
actually take advantage of these
hard-coded locations in memory
where the instruction
pointer needs to get sent to.
So, some of the defenses
that we're about to look at
can actually randomize things
in terms of code layout, heap
layout, and make it a little
difficult for the attacker
to figure out where
things are located.
So, let's look at one simple
mitigation approach first.
So, this is the idea
of stack canaries.
So, the basic idea
behind stack canaries
is that, during a
buffer overflow,
it's actually OK if we allow
the attacker to overwrite
the return address
if we can actually
catch that overwrite before
we actually jump to the place
that the attacker
wants us to go.
So, basically,
here's how it works.
Let's return to
Neal stack diagram.
Essentially we have to think
of it as a magic value.
Basically, in front
of the return address.
Such that any
overflow would have
to hit the canary first, and
then hit the return address.
And if we can check
that canary before we
return from the function,
then we can detect the evil.
So, let's say that, once again,
we've got the buffer here.
Then we're going to
put the canary here.
And then this will be the save
value of the break pointer.
And then this will be
the return address.
So, once again, remember
the overflow goes this way.
So the idea is that
if the overflow wants
to get to that return
address, it first
has to trample on this
canary thing here, right?
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Why does it
have to touch the canary?
PROFESSOR: Well,
because-- assuming
that the attacker
doesn't know how
to jump around in memory
arbitrarily-- the way
that tradionally [INAUDIBLE]
overflow attacks work
is that you look in GB, figure
out where all this stuff is.
And then, you essentially
have this string,
[INAUDIBLE] radius
grows this way.
Now, you're correct that
if the attacker could just
go here directly, then
all the bets are off.
But in the very simple
overflow approach,
everything just has to
grow strictly that way.
So the basic idea
behind the canary
is that we allow the buffer
overflow exploit to take place.
But then we have
run time code that,
at the time of the
return from the function,
is going to check this
canary and make sure
that it has the right value.
Right?
So it's called the canary
because back in the days, when
PETA wasn't around,
you could use
birds to test for evil things.
So that's why it's
called canary.
AUDIENCE: My question
is if the attacker is
able to overwrite the return
address, and modify the canary,
how does he check that the
canary was not modified,
but was going to be performed?
So the attacker overwrites
the return address, right?
So how is the check that
the canary was modified--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So basically, you have to
have some piece of code
that will actually check this
before the return takes place.
So in other words, you're right.
There has to be
that order in there.
So essentially,
what you have to do
is you have to have a support
from the compiler here
that will actually extend
the calling convention,
if you will.
Such that part of
the return sequence
is before we actually
treat this value as valid,
make sure this guy
hasn't been trampled.
Then, and only then, can we
think of going somewhere else.
AUDIENCE: I think I might
be jumping the gun here,
but doesn't this assume
that the attacker
can't find out or guess
what the canary value is?
PROFESSOR: That, in fact, is the
very next thing my lecture is.
If I had prizes, you'd get one.
I don't have any.
But good for you.
Gold star.
That's exactly correct.
So one of the next
things I'd like to say
is what's the problem
with this scheme?
What if, for example,
on every program,
we always put the value a?
Just like four values of a.
So this is like a single
[INAUDIBLE] at work, right?
Then you'd have
that exact problem
that you just mentioned.
Because then, the
attacker-- this
gets back to your question-- he
or she knows how big this is.
This is deterministic
on every system.
So you just make sure
that your buffer overflow
has a bunch of a's here, and
then you overwrite this side.
So you're exactly
right about that.
And so there's basically
different types of values
you could put between this
canary to try to prevent that.
One thing that
you can do here is
you can use-- this is sort of
a very funny type of canary,
but it basically
exploits the ways
that a lot of C
progams and C functions
handle special characters.
So imagine that you used
this value for the canary.
So the binary value is 0,
which is like the null byte,
the null character in ASCII.
Carriage return line feed,
and then the negative 1.
What's funny about this is that
a lot of the functions that you
can exploit-- that manipulate
strings, for example--
they will stop when they
encounter one of these words,
or one of these values.
So you can imagine that you're
using some string manipulation
function to go up this way.
It's going to hit
that null character.
Oops-- it's going
to stop processing.
Right?
Or maybe if you're using
a line-oriented function--
carriage return, line
feed-- that's often
used as the line terminator.
So once again, you're using
that dangerous function
that's trying to go this way.
It hits that.
Oops, it's going to quit.
And the negative 1 is
another similar magic token.
So that's one way you
can get around that.
One second.
And then another
thing you can do
is you can use a
randomized value.
So here, you just [INAUDIBLE]
from this whole idea
of trying to figure out
what exactly it is that
might cause that
attack to terminate.
And you just pull
some random number
and either make it
difficult for the attacker
to guess what that is.
Now, of course, this
random value-- its strength
is basically based on
how difficult it is
for the attacker to guess that.
So the attacker,
for example, can
understand that if
there's only, let's say,
three bits of entropy in your
system, then maybe the attacker
could use some type of forced
attack, so on and so forth.
So one thing to keep
in mind, in general,
is that whenever
someone tells you,
here's a randomized
offense against attack foo,
if there are not a
lot of random bits
there, that attack may not
give you as much defense
as you think.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: Usually
what tends to happen
is you read from another
buffer and you write
into that buffer on the stack.
So in that situation, it seems
like that promiscuous canary
is kind of useless.
Because if I read
from the [INAUDIBLE],
I know what the canary is.
And I have this other
buffer that I control.
And I never check.
And in that buffer, I can
put as much of it as I want.
I don't want the
promiscuous canary,
so I can overwrite
it very safely.
So I don't see how
this really works,
and in what scenario it's--
you're assuming you're reading
from the buffer on this stack
and you're going to stop--
PROFESSOR: Well,
we're assuming--
we're writing to the buffer.
So basically, the idea is that
you write some [? two-long ?]
string this way.
And then the idea is that if you
can't guess what this is, then
you can't, basically, put this
value inside of your overflow
string.
AUDIENCE: But you said
it's deterministic, right?
0, CR, LF, negative 1.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Right.
OK.
So I think I understand
your question now.
Yes.
If you use this system here,
with the deterministic canary,
and you essentially
are not using
one of these functions
from, let's say,
the standard library that
would be fooled by this,
then, yeah, you can defeat
the system that way.
AUDIENCE: But I
can use string CPIs
and the destination
can be buffered.
And the source can
be [INAUDIBLE].
And that would not
protect me against that.
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure I
understand the attack, so.
AUDIENCE: So the string
CPI would take home
the user input for my data,
would overwrite canary-- oh,
and you're saying--
hmm, actually, I
understand what you're saying.
PROFESSOR: Right?
Because the idea is that you
can fill this buffer with bytes
from wherever, right?
But the idea is that
unless you can guess this,
then it doesn't matter.
But you're correct.
In general, anything that allows
you to guess this or randomly
get that value correct will
lead to the feed of the system.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of [INAUDIBLE],
can you just take something
like the number of seconds
or milliseconds since
the epoch and use
that at the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
as it turns out,
a lot of times, calls
that get [INAUDIBLE]
don't contain as much
randomness as you might think.
Because the program
itself might somehow--
let's say, for example, have a
log statement or function you
could call to get the
time that the program was
launched or things like that.
But you're right.
In practice, if you
can use something like,
let's say, the hardware system
plot, which is often the lowest
level, better system of timing
of it-- yes, that kind of thing
might work.
AUDIENCE: But even if
you can pull the logs,
it still depends on exactly
what time you refuse a request.
And so if you don't have
control over how long it takes
for your requests to get from
your computer to the server,
then I don't think you
can deterministically
guess exactly the right time.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
The devil's in the details
with all this kind of stuff.
In other words, if there's
some way for you to figure out,
for example, that type
of timing channel,
you might find out that the
amount of entropy-- the amount
of randomness--
is not, let's say,
the full size of a timestamp,
but maybe something
that's much smaller.
Because maybe the
attacker can figure out
the hour and the
minute in which you
did this, but not the
second, for example.
We'll take one more
question, then we'll move on.
AUDIENCE: For the record, trying
to roll your own randomness
is usually a bad idea, right?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Usually,
you should just
use whatever's supplied
by your systems.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
That's very true.
It's like inventing your
own cryptosystem, which
is another popular thing
undergrads sometimes
want to do.
We're not the NSA, we're
not mathematicians.
That typically fails.
So you're exactly
right about that.
But even if you use
system-supplied randomness,
you still may end up with
fewer bits of entropy
than you expect.
And I'll give you an example
of that when we talk about
address phase randomization.
So that's basically how the
stack canary approach works.
And so since we're in a security
class, you might be wondering,
so what kinds of things will
stack canaries not catch?
So when do canaries fail?
One way they can fail
is if the attacker
the things, like
function pointers.
Because if function
pointers get [INAUDIBLE],
there's nothing
that the canary can
do to prevent that type of
exploit from taking place.
For example, let's say you have
code that declared a pointer.
It gets initialized in some
way, it doesn't really matter.
Then you have a buffer here.
Once again, the gets
function rears its ugly head.
And then, let's say, down
here, we assign some value 5
for the pointer.
Now note that we
haven't actually
tried to attack the return
address of the function that
contains this code.
When we view the
buffer overflow,
this pointer address up here
is going to get corrupted.
And so what ends up happening
is that if the attacker can
corrupt that pointer,
then the attacker's
able to write 5 to some
attacker-controlled address.
Does everyone see how the
canary doesn't help here?
Because we're
basically not attacking
the way that the
function returns.
AUDIENCE: But won't the
pointer be below the buffer?
PROFESSOR: So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily--
PROFESSOR: So you're worried
about, is it going to be here,
or is it going to be here?
AUDIENCE: I'm worried
about when you--
will you actually be able to
access where the pointer is
when you're overturning--
PROFESSOR: Ah, yeah.
So you can't necessarily--
that's a good question.
So I think, in a lot of
the previous examples,
you've been assuming that
this guy would be here.
Like, in the [INAUDIBLE].
If the stack is going
this way, then the pointer
would be down here.
But the order of the
particular variables--
it depends on a bunch
of different things.
It depends on the way that
the compiler lays stuff out.
It depends on the column
dimension of the hardware,
so on and so forth.
But you're right that
if the-- basically,
if the buffer overflow
was going this way,
but the pointer was in
front of the buffer,
then it's going to work.
AUDIENCE: Why can't
you associate a canary
with the function
canary, just like you
did with the return address?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
That's an interesting point.
You could do those things.
In fact, you could try
to imagine a compiler
that, whenever it had
any pointer whatsoever,
it would always try to add
padding for various things.
Right?
As it turns out, it seems
like that will quickly
get expensive, in terms
of all the code that's
added, to have to check for
all those types of things.
Because then you could imagine
that every single time you
want to invoke any pointer,
or recall any function,
you've got to have
this code that's
going to check whether
that canary is correct.
But yeah, in principle, you
could do something like that.
So does this make sense?
So we see that canaries don't
help you on this equation.
And so another thing, as
we've discussed before,
is that if you can guess the
randomness, then, basically,
the random canaries don't work.
Producing secure
sources of randomness
is actually a topic
in and of itself.
That's very, very
complicated, so we're not
going to go into great
depth about that here.
But suffice it to say, if
you can guess the randomness,
everything falls apart.
AUDIENCE: So do canaries usually
have less bits than the return
address?
Because otherwise,
couldn't you just
memorize the return address and
check that the address changed?
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
So you're saying if the
canary here is, let's say,
smaller than--
AUDIENCE: I'm saying for
the canary is that you know
what that value is [INAUDIBLE].
Can't you also memorize
the return address value
and check if that's
been changed?
PROFESSOR: Oh, so you're saying
can't the secure system--
can't it look at
the return address
and figure out if
that's been changed.
Yeah.
In other words, if
there-- well, yes and no.
Note that there's
still this that's
going get overwritten in
the buffer overflow attack.
So this may still
cause problems.
But in principle, if
somehow these things
were invariant somehow, then you
could do something like that.
But the problem is
that, in many cases,
this return-- the
bookkeeping overhead for that
would be a little bit tricky.
Because you can imagine
that particular function
may be called from places,
and so on and so forth.
Just in the interest
of time, we're
going to zoom
forward a little bit.
But if we have time
at the end, we'll
come back to some
of these questions.
So those are some situations
in which the canary can fail.
There's some other places
in which it can fail, too.
For example, one way
that it might fail
is with malloc and free attacks.
This is a uniquely
C-style attack.
Let's see what happens here.
Imagine that you have two
pointers here, p and q.
And then imagine that we issue
a malloc for both of these.
We give p 1,024 bytes of memory.
We also give q 1,024
bytes of memory.
And then, let's say
that we do a strcpy on p
from some bug that's
controlled by the attacker.
So here's where the
overflow happens.
And then let's say
that would be free q
and then let's say
that would be free p.
OK.
So it's fairly
straightforward code, right?
Two pointers-- malloc's the
memory for each one of them.
You use one of these
on site functions,
the buffer overflow happens,
and we free q and we free p.
Let's assume that p and
q-- the memory that's
assigned to them-- are nearby,
in terms of the layout in terms
of [INAUDIBLE].
So both of these objects
line next to each other
in the memory space.
There's some subtle and evil
things that can happen, right?
Because this third copy
here might actually over--
it'll fill p with
a bunch of stuff,
but it might also corrupt some
of the state that belongs to q.
OK?
And this can cause problems.
And some of you may
have done things
in this unintentionally
in your own code, when
you have some type of
weird use of pointers.
And then stuff seems
to work, but when
you call free later
on, it segfaults
or something like that.
Right?
What I'm going to
talk about here
is the way that the
attacker can take
advantage of that behavior.
We're actually going to
explain why that happens.
So imagine that inside
the implementation
of free and malloc, an
allocated block looks like this.
So let's say that there is the
app-visible data that lives up
here.
And then let's say you had
a size variable down here.
This is not something that
the application sees directly.
This is like some
bookkeeping info
that the free or
the malloc systems
attract so that you know
the sizes of the buffer
that it allocated.
Let's say that free block
has some metadata that
looks like this.
You've got the size of
the free block here.
And then you've got a
bunch of empty space here.
Then let's say-- this is
where things get interesting.
You've got a backwards
pointer and then
you've got a forward pointer.
And maybe you've got
some size data here.
Now why are we having
these two pointers here?
It's because the
memory allocation
system, in this case, is
using a doubly-linked list
to track how the free blocks
related to each other.
So when you allocate
a free block,
you take it off of this
doubly-linked list.
And then when you deallocate it,
you do some pointer arithmetic,
and then you fix
these things up.
Then you add it back to
that linked list, right?
So as always, whenever you
hear pointer arithmetic,
you should think
it's your canary.
Because that's where a lot
of these problems come about.
And so the thing to note is
that we had this buffer overflow
here, the p.
If we assume that p and
q are next to each other,
or very close in memory, then
what can end up happening
is that this buffer
overflow can overwrite
some of this size data for
the allocated pointer, q.
Is everybody with me so far?
Because if you're with me
so far, then basically,
you can use your
imagination at this point
and see where things go wrong.
Because essentially,
what's going
to end up happening is that
these free operations-- they
look at this metadata to do all
kinds of pointer manipulations
with this kind of stuff.
Somewhere in the
implementation of free,
it's going to get
some pointer based
on the value of size,
where size is something
the attacker controls.
Because the attacker
did the buffer overflow.
Right?
So then, you can
imagine that it does
a bunch of pointer arithmetic.
So it's going to look
at the back in the four
pointers of this block.
And then it's going
to do something
like update the back pointer.
And also update the
forward pointer.
And the exact
specifics of this-- you
don't need to worry about.
This is just an example of the
code that takes place in there.
But the point is that note
that because the attacker's
overwritten size,
the attacker now
controls this pointer that's
passed into the free code.
And because of that,
these two statements
here, these are actually
pointer updates.
Right?
This is a pointer somewhere.
And because the attacker has
been able to control this p,
he actually controls
all this stuff, too.
This is where the attack
can actually take place.
So when the free
code operates and it
tries to do things like,
for example, merge these two
blocks, that's
typically why you have
[INAUDIBLE] doubly-linked list.
Because if you have two blocks
that are facing to each other
and they're both free, you want
to merge them to one big block.
Well, we control size.
That means we control
this whole process here.
That means if we've been clever
in how these overflows are
working, at these points, we
can write to a memory in the way
that we choose.
Does that make sense?
And like I said,
this type of thing
often happens in your own
code when you're not getting
very clever with pointer.
When you make some mistake with
the double freeing or whatever,
this is why stuff will
segfault sometimes.
Because you've messed
up this metadata
that lives with each one
of these allocated blocks.
And then at some
point, this calculation
will point to some garbage
value, and then you're dead.
But if you're the attacker, you
can actually choose that value
and use it for
your own advantage.
OK.
So now let's get
to another approach
for getting rid of some of
these buffer overflow attacks.
And that approach
is bounds checking.
The goal of bounds
checking is to make sure
that when you use a
particular pointer,
it only refers to something
that is a memory object.
And that pointer's in the valid
bounds of that memory object.
So that's the basic
idea behind the idea.
It's actually pretty
simple-- at a high level.
Once again, in C, though,
it's very difficult
to actually understand things.
Like, what does it
actually mean for a pointer
to be in bounds or out of
bounds, or valid or invalid?
So for example, let's
say that you have
two pieces of code like this.
So you declare a character
array of 1,024 bytes.
And then let's say that you
use something like this.
You declare a pointer,
and then you'd
get the address of one
of the elements in x.
Does this make sense?
Is this a good idea to do that?
It's hard to say.
If you're treating this
x up here as a string,
maybe it makes sense for Jim
to take a pointer like this.
Then you can increment and
decrement, because maybe you're
looking for some special value
of your character in there.
But if this is a network
message or something like that,
maybe there's actually some
struct that's embedded in here.
So it doesn't
actually make sense
to walk this character
by character, right?
So the challenge here
is that, once again, we
can see it allows you
to do whatever you want.
It's hard to determine what it
is you actually want it to do.
And so, as a result,
it's a little bit
subtle with how
you define things
like pointer safety in C.
You can also imagine that life
gets even more complicated
if you use structs and unions.
Imagine you had a union.
It would look like this.
It's got some integer
value in there.
And then you've got some struct.
And then, it has two
integers inside of it.
Don't forget the way that the
unions work is that, basically,
the union's going to
allocate the maximum size
for the largest element.
At any given moment,
you typically
expect that either
this ni will be valid
or this struct s will
be valid, but not both.
So imagine that you had code
that did something like this.
You get a pointer
to address this guy.
So I get an integer pointer to
the address of, in the union,
this struct, and then k.
Well, this reference is
strictly speaking in bounds.
There's memory that's
been allocated for this.
That's not incorrect.
But are you actually, this
moment in program of execution,
treating this union
as one of these guys
or one of these guys?
It's hard to say.
So as a result of these
ambiguous pointers semantics
that can arise in these
C programs, typically,
these bound checking
approaches can only
offer a weaker notion
of pointer correctness.
And so that notion
is as follows.
If you have a pointer
p prime that's
derived from the base
pointer p, then p prime
should only be used to
deference memory that belongs
to the original base pointer.
So for a derived
pointer p prime that's
derived from some
original p, then
p prime should only be used
to deference memory that
belongs to p.
Know that this is a weaker
goal than enforcing completely
correct pointer semantics.
Because for example,
you could still
have weird issues like with
this union here, for example.
Maybe at this particular
point in the program,
it wasn't correct
for the program
to be able to reference that
particular value in the union.
But at least this pointer
reference is imbalanced.
So maybe-- like this example
up here-- maybe this creation
of this pointer here
violated the semantics
of the network
message embedded in x.
But at least you're not
trampling on arbitrary memory.
You're only trampling on the
memory that belongs to you.
And so, in the world of C,
this is considered success.
So that's the basic idea.
Now, the challenge
with enforcing
these types of semantics
here is that, in many cases,
you need help from the compiler.
So you need help
from the compiler.
You typically need
to recompile programs
to enforce these semantics.
That can be a drag for
backwards compatibility.
But this is the basic
notion of bounds checking.
What are some ways that you
can implement bounds checking?
One very simple way is this
notion called electric fencing.
The notion here is that, for
every object that you allocate
on the heap, you allocate
a guard page that's
immediately next to it.
And you set the page
protection on that page, such
that if anybody tries to touch
that, you get a hard fault.
The hard rules say
that's out of bounds,
and then the program
will stop right there.
And so this is a very simple
thing that you can do.
And what's nice about
this approach actually,
is that whenever you have
an invalid memory reference,
this causes a fault
immediately, right.
If you've ever debugged
the Base C or C++ program,
one of the big problems is that
a lot of times when you corrupt
memory, that memory is corrupted
silently, and for a while,
and it isn't until later that
something crashes and then only
then you realize
something happened.
But you don't know
what that something is.
You simply do what they
call heisenbugs, right.
Things that have this notion
of uncertainty in them.
So what's nice about
this is that as soon
as the pointer hits here,
boom, it's a guard page,
everything blows up.
Now can you think
of a disadvantage
with this approach?
AUDIENCE: It takes
longer [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah exactly.
So imagine that this
little-- this key thing here
was super, super small, then
I've allocated a whole page
just to make sure that my little
tiny thing here didn't get--
didn't have one of
these pointer attacks.
So this is very space intensive.
And so-- but people don't
really deploy something
like this in production.
This could be useful
for the bugging thing,
but you would never do
this for a real program.
So that make sense?
So these electrical fences
are actually pretty-- pretty
simple to understand.
AUDIENCE: Why does that have
to be so large, necessarily?
PROFESSOR: Ah, so the reason is
because this guard page here,
you're typically relying on
the hardware, like page level
protections to deal with
those types of things.
And so there's like
certain memory size
you can set to the size
of the page, according to
[? Hollis ?].
But typically that page
is 4k, for example.
So getting back
to your question,
this is some like
super small value here,
then yeah [INAUDIBLE]
2 bytes where
you got 4k here protecting it.
AUDIENCE: In protecting
[INAUDIBLE] individual
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh sorry
yeah, yeah so by heap I
mean like heap object.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah thank
you for-- yeah exactly.
So imagine like for
each malloc you do,
you can have one of these--
and set the guard page for it.
AUDIENCE: And you do
it for log and above?
Or just above?
PROFESSOR: You can do either.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right,
well you could do either.
The ones we have
depending on this--
on the size of the object.
I mean now you got to declare
two guard fences, right.
So now this quickly
gets out of control.
Which yeah, you could have
a booking [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the basic
idea behind that.
And then another
approach you can look at
is what they call fat pointers.
And so the idea
here is we actually
want to modify the pointer
representation itself
to include bounds
information in it.
So if you look at your regular
32-bit pointer what's it
look like?
Well the answer is, 32-bits.
And then you got [INAUDIBLE].
Right?
If you look at a
fat pointer then one
way you can think
about looking at this
is you got a 4 byte base.
And then you have a 4 byte end.
So in other words, this is
where it would allocate out
that it starts,
that's where it ends
and then you've got
a 4 byte cur address.
So this is where
the pointer actually
is, within that bounds, right.
So basically what happens is
that the compiler will generate
code, such that when you access
these fat pointers this gets
updated, but then it'll
also check these two things
to make sure that
nothing bad has
happened during that upgrade.
So for example you can imagine
that if I had code like this.
So I have an end pointer
and then I allocate 8 bytes.
So assuming that we're
on a 32-bit architecture
to point to 2 [INAUDIBLE].
And then I have some
while loop that it
is going to just assign some
value to the pointer and then
increment the pointer--
what you'll see
is that the current
address for this pointer,
like at this point in code,
will point to the base, right.
And then every time we
iterate through here,
we can see that we're
either checking a bound,
or incrementing a bound.
So at this point we
want to dereference it.
We can actually check and
see, is the current address
at that pointer, in this ring.
And if it's not you
throw in an exception
here and so on and so forth.
So once again, where
is this taking place?
This Is taking place in new code
that the compiler generated.
So one question that came up
on the online discussion group,
some people were
saying, well what
if it's instrumented code,
what does that mean, right?
So when I say that the--
that the compiler generates
new code, imagine
that there-- this is
what you see as a programmer.
But before this operation
actually takes place,
imagine the compiler
inserted some new C code here
that basically looks at
these base bounds here.
And then if there was
something out of bounds
it would then do an exit, or an
abort, or something like that.
So that's what it
means to say that there
is instrumented code.
It's that you take the source
code, use the program of C,
add some new C source
code and then compile
that video program.
So the basic idea I think
behind the fat pointer
is pretty simple.
There's some
disadvantages to this.
The biggest
disadvantage is that, oh
my goodness look how big
the pointers are now, right.
And so what this means
is that you can't just
take a fat pointer and
pass it to an unmodified,
off the shell library.
Because it may have
certain expectations
that pointers are a certain
size and we give you this thing,
it's just going to--
it's going to blow up.
We also have trouble
if you want to include
these types of pointers and
structs, or things like that.
Because that can actually change
the size of the struct, right.
So a very popular
thing in C code to do
is to take like the
size of the struct
and then like do something
as a result of that.
Like reserve some disc space
for a struct of that size,
and so on and so forth.
So this causes all that
stuff to blow up, right.
Because once again, the pointers
have gotten very, very big.
And another thing
which is a bit subtle,
but it's that these
fat pointers typically
will not be able to be updated
in an atomic fashion, right.
So on 32-bit
architectures typically,
if you do like a write
to a 32-bit variable,
that write is atomic, right.
But now, these pointers are
these three integer sized
things, right.
So if you have any code that
takes advantage of the fact
that it expects pointer
writes to be atomic,
then you may get
in trouble, right.
Because you can imagine that
to do some of these checks,
you have to look at the current
address and then look at this
and then you might
have to increment
that, and so on and so forth.
So this can cause very
subtle concurrency bugs
if you have code that depends
on that atomacy of fail
[INAUDIBLE].
So does that all make sense?
So that's one
approach you can do.
But kind of like
electric fences, this
has some nasty side effects
that means the people don't
typically use that in practice.
So now we can start talking
about bounds checking,
with respect to the shadow
of the infrastructure
that I mentioned in
the baggy bounds paper.
So the basic idea for
the shadow base structure
is for each object
that you allocate,
you want to store how
big the object is.
Right, so for example,
if you have some pointer
that you call
malloc on right, you
need to store that size
of that object there,
and then note that if you
have some thing that's
like a static variable
like this, right,
the compiler can
automatically figure out
what the bounds
are for that thing
there, statically speaking.
So for each one
of these pointers
you need to interpose
somehow on two operations.
Basically you do arithmetic.
So this is things like q
equals p plus 7, or whatever.
And then you want to
interpose on dereferencing.
So this is something
like q equals
a or something like that.
So what's interesting
is that you might think,
well why can't we just
rely on the reference
when interposing stuff?
Why do we have to look at
this point arithmetic here?
But similarly you might
wonder the other thing.
Like why can't you
just deal with one
of these non [INAUDIBLE]
interpose [INAUDIBLE]?
So you can't just
signal an error
if you see the arithmetic going
out of bounds because in c
that may or may not be there.
So in other words, a very common
medium is C and C++ is you
might have a pointer that
points to one pass the valid end
of an object right, and then you
use that as a stop condition,
right.
So you iterate to the
object and once you
hit that end pointer, that's
when you actually stop the loop
or whatever.
So if we just
interpose on arithmetic
and we always
cause a hard fault,
when we see a pointer
go out of bounds,
that may actually break a lot of
legitimate applications, right.
So we can't just
interpose on that.
And so you might say, well
why can't you just interpose
on the reference thing, and
you just-- when we notice
that you've cut
something out of bounds,
we'll just read there and there.
Well the challenge
there is that how do
you know it's out of bounds?
Right, it's the-- it's the
arithmetic in our positioning
that officially allows
us to tell whether or not
this thing's going to
be legal here, right.
Because it's the
interpositioning
on the arithmetic that
allows us to track
where the pointer
is with respect
to it's original baseline.
So that's the basic idea there.
And so the next question
is how do we actually
implement the bounds checking?
Because basically we need some
way to map a particular pointer
address to some type of bounds
information for that pointer.
And so a lot of your
previous solutions
use things like, for example,
like a hash table, or a tree,
right that will allow
you to do lookups right,
and stay the gray.
So given a pointer
address, I do some lookup
in this data structure, figure
out what the bounds are.
Given those bounds I
can then figure out
if I want to allow the
action to take place or not.
Now the problem with that
is that it's a slow lookup,
right because these data
structures you're thinking it's
a tree, or you're going
through a bunch of branches
before you can actually
hit the value potentially.
And even if it's a hash
table where there's
an overflow in the bucket
you got to follow chains,
or do you're code,
or things like that.
So the baggy bounds
paper that we
are about to look at
actually figured out
a very efficient data structure
that tracked to these bounds,
to make that bound
checking very fat.
So let's just step
into that right now.
But before we go into
that let me very briefly
talk about how buddy
allocation works.
Because that's one of
the things that came up
in a lot of the questions.
So one thing you will see for
these papers is that a lot
of times they are not
self-contained, right.
So they will mention things that
they will assume that you know,
but you may not know them.
Don't get discouraged by that.
That happens to
me too sometimes.
These papers are
written in a way
they assume a lot
of prior knowledge,
so don't get
discouraged by that.
Luckily we actually
access to the internet
we can look up
some of that stuff.
Can you imagine what
happened in our parents time?
They just didn't
understand stuff they just
had to go home, right.
So don't be afraid to look
stuff up to get to Wikipedia
it's mostly correct.
So how does-- how does the
buddy allocation system work?
So basically what
it does at first
it treats unallocated
memory as one big block.
OK.
And then when you
request a smaller block
for dynamic allocation, it
tries to split that address
base using powers of 2
until it finds a block that
is just big enough to work.
So let's say a request
came in and say A
is going to equal to malloc 28.
28 bytes.
And let's just say
this toy example is
only 128 bytes of memory total.
So the buddy allocator
is going to look at this
and say, well I have
128 bytes of memory,
but it's too wasteful to
allocate this whole thing
to this 28 byte request.
So I'm going to split
this request in two
and then see if I have smaller
block that's just big enough.
So it's going to say, OK put
this to 0 to 64 and 64 to 128.
Ah OK, but this block here
is still too big, right.
Basically what the buddy
algorithm wants to do
is find a block such
that the allocated
data in the real
object, 28 bytes,
is at least half the
size of that block.
So buddy allocator says,
OK this thing over here
is still too big.
So what it's going to do is
it's going to split the memory
space again, right.
So from 0 to 32 and
then it's going to say,
ah OK 28 bytes that is more
than half the size of this block
here.
So now this block is going
to be allocated to A. OK,
and so it gets
this address here.
Now let's say that we have
another question comes in for B
and let's say we want
to malloc 50 right.
So what's going to happen is
that the buddy allocator will
say, ah OK I actually
have a block here
that's big enough, right.
50 Is greater than half
the size of this thing
so I'll just allocate
that right there.
So we have this system, or
setup, where we have A here,
and then we have
B here, and then
let's say we had another request
that came in for 20 bytes.
This is actually
pretty straightforward
because we can put
that right here, right.
So then you have something
that looks like this.
Then what's interesting is that
when you deallocate memory,
if you have to
deallocate a block that
are next to each other
and are the same size,
the buddy allocator
will merge them
into a block that's
twice as big, right.
So if we had free let's say C
then we go to this situation,
we can't do any merging, because
this is the only possible block
that this one could
have been merged with.
It's the same size, but
this things still occupied.
So then if we do a
free on A, then we
have this situation here.
Right, where these
two 32 byte blocks
were merged into one size 64,
and that this one, a size 64
is still out there.
Right, so it's called the buddy
system because once again,
whenever you have two
adjacent blocks that
are of the same
size and that could
be merged to form
an aligned block,
then the system will merge that
buddy with this other buddy
and then create that new
block that's twice as big.
So the thing that's
nice about this system
is that it's very simple to
figure out where buddy's are.
Because you can do
very cutesy arithmetic,
like the buddy bounds system--
baggy bounds system works.
But anyway I'm not
going into details.
This is basically how
buddy allocation works.
Does that make sense?
Right, and one
question that came up
a lot in all my discussions,
isn't this wasteful?
Right, so for example, imagine
that up here at the beginning
I had a request for
size 65 bytes, right.
So if I have a
request for 65 bytes,
I would allocate this whole
structure up here and then
there's-- actually you're out of
dynamic memory and can't do any
more allocations.
And the answer is
yes, that is wasteful.
But once again, it's
a trade off, right.
Because it's very easy to do
these calculations on how to do
merging and stuff like that.
So if you want finer
grain allocation,
there are other
valid ones for that.
It's outside the scope
of the lecture so,
we can buffer that
offline if you want.
That's basically how the buddy--
sorry the, the buddy allocator
works.
So what is the baggy
bounds system going to do?
Well, it is going through
a y, on couple of tricks.
So the first idea is you
round up each allocation
to a power of 2, and you align
the request to that power of 2.
Right, so essentially the
buddy allocators very nice
because it handles a lot
of that for you, right.
It naturally will do
that kind of thing.
Because that's just the way that
it allocates and deallocates
to memory.
And so the second thing
that's going to happen,
baggy bounds system, is you
express each bound as log base
2 of the allocation size.
Right, and so what this means--
and so why can we do this?
Well once again all of
our allocation sizes
are powers of 2, right.
So we don't need very
many bits to represent
how big a particular
allocation size is.
So for example, if your
allocation size is 16,
then you just need
four-- the log rhythm
of that, 4 bits of the
allocation size, right.
Does that make sense?
Right, this another
popular question here.
This is why you only
need small number of bits
here, because we're
basically forcing
the allocation sizes hit this
quantized way that you grow.
Like if you could
only have something,
let's say 16 bytes or 32 bytes.
You can't have for
example, 33 bytes.
And then the third thing that
baggy bounds is going to do
is store the limit info in a
linear array 1 byte per entry
but we're going
to allocate memory
at the granularity of a slot.
Which in the paper they used
16 bytes as the slot width.
So for example,
now this next one,
this is 1 bit that wasn't
actually specifically said
in the paper which
if you don't grasp
it'll make the paper very
tricky to understand, right.
So now you can have a slot
size which is equal to 16,
so if you do p equals malloc
16 so what's going to happen?
So in this bounds
table you're going
to say take that pointer
plot it by plot size it's
going to equal 4, right.
So in that bounds
table we're going
to put the logarithm of the
allocation size in the table.
Does that make sense?
OK, now what the
tricky thing is,
let's say that you have
something like this.
Right, so let's say
that you out 32 bytes.
What is the bounds table
going to look like there?
So here we actually have
to update the bounds
table to abbreviate your p, or
sorry t for the size you need.
But that fit the
bounds table twice.
Right, once for the
first slot memory
that this allocation takes up.
And then a second time for that
second slot that it takes up.
Right, so once again 32
is the allocation size.
This is the log of
that allocation size.
So for the two slots that
this memory takes up,
we're going to update
the bounds table twice.
Does that makes sense?
Right, and this
is really the key
that I think for a
lot of people that's
going to make the paper make
sense or not make sense, right.
Because that bounds table
multiple times if any
outside the allocation.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
that for me again?
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat that again?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah,
yeah, sure, sure.
So basically what
the idea is that I
mean you've got this
bounds table here
and it's got a bunch of entries.
But it basically
needs entries to cover
all of p size, all
the allocation size.
OK, so in this case it was very
simple because basically this
is just one slot,
due to the size.
Here it's multiple
slot sizes, right.
So what's going to happen
is that imagine then
that we had a pointer that's
moving in the range of p.
You have to have some
of the back end table
slot for each one of those
places where p [INAUDIBLE],
right.
And so it's this
second piece that
makes the paper a little
bit confusing I think.
But it doesn't really go
into depth about that,
but this is how that works.
OK so armed with
the bounds table
stuff what happens if we have
a C code that looks like this?
So you have a pointer,
p-prime, you derive it from p,
we would add some variable i.
So how do you get the size of
the allocation belonging to p?
Well you look in the table
using this lookup here.
Right, so the size of the data
that's been allocated to p
is going to be equal to
1 and then when you Left
Shift that by
looking at the table,
taking that pointer value,
and then Right Shifting that
by the log of the table size.
Right, if the
arithmetic works out
because of the way
that we're binding
pointers to the
table bounds, right.
So this will get us-- this
thing right here, will get us
the log of the sides.
And then this thing
over here basically
expands that into like
the regular value, right.
So for example, if the
size of this pointer
were 32, in terms of bytes
we've allocated, right.
This is going to get us five
when we look at the table,
then when we Left
Shift it this way, Left
Shift the one this
way, then we're
going to get 32 back
again from here.
OK.
And then we want to find
the base of that pointer.
Take a pointer
itself and then we're
going to and that
with the side minus 1.
Now what this is going to
do is, this is actually
going to give us a mass,
that you can think of it.
And that mass is going to allow
us to recover the base here.
So imagine that
your size equals 16.
So 16 equals this in binary.
Right, there's a bunch
of zeros off this way.
So we've got a 1 here, we've
got some zeros over here.
So if we look at the bit-wide
inverse of 16 minus 1,
then-- actually sorry.
So if we look at 16 minus 1, so
what's that going to look like?
60 minus 1 we're going to
look like right, something
like this.
OK.
And if we take the
inverse of that
what is that going to give us?
Right, in binary.
So basically this thing here
allows us to basically clear
the bit that essentially
would be offset
from that valid pointer
and just give us
the base of that pointer.
OK.
And so once we've
got this, then it's
very simple to check whether
this pointer's in bounds,
right.
So we can basically just
check whether p-prime
is greater than or equal
to base and whether p-prime
minus the base is
less than size.
This is just a straightforward
thing you do, right.
Just seeing whether
that derived pointer
exists within the bounds
of this [INAUDIBLE].
Right, so at this point things
are pretty straightforward.
Now they have like a
optimized check in the paper,
I'm not going to go
into that detail.
But suffice it to say that
all the binary arithmetic,
it resolves down
to the same thing.
There's just some
clever tricks there
to avoid some of the explicit
calculations we do here.
That's the basic idea.
And so the fifth trick that
the baggy bounds system uses
is that it uses the virtual
memory system to prevent out
of bounds [INAUDIBLE] right.
So the idea here is
that-- how much time
do we have by the way?
Probably like zero?
So the basic idea
here is that if we
have a pointer [INAUDIBLE]
here, that we detect
is out of bounds, what we can do
is actually set the high order
bit on a pointer, right.
And by doing that we guarantee
that pointer is dereferenced,
then the caging hardware's
going to be [INAUDIBLE],
we're going to throw
a hard error, right.
Now in and of
itself, just setting
that bit does not
cause a problem.
It's only when you
dereference that pointer
that you get into problems.
OK?